[Music]
hello everyone this is endgame exclam
and I'm your host
Dennis boorish this is going to be a
wonderful lecture
hopefully first off who is the best end
game player at the moment Vishy Anand
he's a very good one kappa blanka is
pretty good but not of this century
Aronian and we have one favorite that we
can read father so today I'm going to
show how cousin turns into fairly solid
middle games into winning and games and
that will be the subject of our lecture
first and foremost I want to start with
the games he played against Gelfand
and I think this was crucial for his bid
for the World Championship if you don't
know he went 2-0 against Gaffin with
both colors and I think that weighted
heavily for his bid for the title so
without further ado let's start before
no surprises here whenever you prepare
for gelfand you know that he always has
stock openings can anybody help me what
stock openings gaff on plays please
raise your hand if you have an idea yes
c5 of course but that's just the
Sicilian that's just the beginning of
the story Knight f3 knight c6 what could
be gallons in tension here yes
that's not an opening so what is Galvan
preparing to do after d4 can you raise
your hand please thank you thank you so
much thank you
it is this rushing to go yes you're
correct so C takes d4 Knight takes d4
Knight f6 Knight c3 c5 and the good
thing with white against Wesley Cove but
after studying for 50 hours you get a
plus equal position that you will never
win
therefore cousin chose Bishop b5 which
is more of like let's get ready to
rumble and fight on the chess board
ecigs Castle 97 rook e1 a6 bishop f1 now
bishop f1 seems to be a very passive
move but what does Bishop f1 avoid in
general for white
well it avoids exchanging of this bishop
and as we know cause then he respects
bishop bishops immensely just like
Fisher say plays Bishop f1 d5 he takes
d5 Knight takes d5 d4 and we get this
typical Sicilian positions that for the
untrained eye I might seem very plain
which is not the case Knight f6 how can
we defend this d4 pawn well yes
c3 but that would actually lead to
isolated pawn and Carson does not want
to play with a nice lyonie
yep okay
yeah there should be three so cousin
puts all his pieces there to protect
this d4 square C takes d4 Knight takes
d4 and as I point out white will have a
majority okay that doesn't work but
let's see if this works
yes so why does have a majority on the
queenside which will be pivotal in the
endgame so khasinau finds a very simple
plan exchange of all the pieces c4
Knight takes d4 and then hint side maybe
taking on d4 is not a great idea because
cousin is happy about exchanges if you
think about the majority that he has on
the Queen side so Knight d4 Bishop d4
Bishop c6 thank you Knight c3 Bishop e7
and cousin starts a plan that actually
kind of implies a little bit of movement
on the Queen side he's planning to roll
his pawns how did he kind of initiate
that plan what will why play here are
you relaxing your hand or you have a is
that both relaxing and yes with the plan
yeah to play b4 so cousin is trying to
move these pawns like rolling stones and
fortunately or hopefully for him he
could succeed okay now galvan doesn't
want any of that
Queen d3 castles rogue d1 Queen c7
Bishop e5 Queen b6 Queen g3 rook d8 now
if we don't understand this position we
might think this is just plain equal but
in the long term these pawns will prove
effective
first off bishop c7 doesn't work because
I can take on d1 and if you take my
queen I get the second rook and that
will be roughly equal now when we have
middle game positions you have to
realize what we should be doing now the
queen is primarily attacking the g7 pawn
and puts a lot of pressure on the black
king side but what's our general plan
for white can anybody help me with that
yes Jade pieces so what should cause and
play in this position yes
if you take on f6 you get rid of a
wonderful bishop on e5 and also cousin
if you will notice
I mean you will notice that Kazem
actually likes his bishops he doesn't
like to give them away for free yes yes
if Knight e4 I'll take you with Knight
Bishop yes
Bishop c7 then I'll just take on the one
with the rook and I'll take on anyone
yes yeah rook takes d8 first that's what
cousin played Queen d8 now and then the
second time if rook d8 now Bishop c7
works because there's no ruk takes on d1
anymore so that would end the game quite
quickly so Queen takes d8 rogue d1 now
he controls the center Queen b6 Bishop
d4 he's kind of trying to chase the
screen away to a more uncomfortable
position Queen b3 and now he plays the
splendid move rook d3 now if black would
be bet greedy he would find himself in
trouble after check check and rook da
check because that would just drop the
Queen so obviously Galvan doesn't fall
for this and just remember this is the
candidates tournament whoever wins this
tournament will qualify for the World
Championship so there's a lot at stake
Queen c2 and now comes the gold star
move for white
before black takes first sticks but he
can't stake because just bishop takes up
six and it drops a piece and amazing
attack correct instead he goes not age
five what Dan Kazem comes up with
another great move centralizing all his
pieces yes
yes Queeny five actually kind of pseudo
threatening Queen g7 mate which will
never happen but it's not a fun thing to
see your opponent setting up batteries
like that so it goes Bishop f6 which is
actually short term peace sacrifice but
after Bishop d4 there's a double attack
on there's a double attack on F 2 and C
3 so what must take between takes c3 and
now I guess the move that Galvan truly
missed comes up it seems that cousin is
in trouble
the b4 pawn is in danger the d4 rook is
a bit loose but cousin sees a move that
will turn everything around
yes Queen h4 p h4 I take on b4 and if
you take I go back to f8 yes yes Queen
a5 very great move because after it
takes we just check indeed and we just
checkmate with one sole rook rook f8 and
then we have a position where we already
have a majority that we've been building
all day long for 28 moves already and we
will and we already see the strategy
that cousin built for the candidates
he's going for long-term advantages
instead of these little small advantages
that could wane and are mostly studied
by the opponents
so here cousin plays Queen b6 putting
pressure on the b7 pawn and also
threatening B fives b5 will d1 in yes
just as I mentioned before blacks pawns
are not as treacherous as White's two
pawns which could potentially become big
hazards for black
position g6 b5 Bishop b4 can anybody
help me why why played b5 yes well one
reason is to pushing the pawn far yes
and what's the other reason
mm-hmm one of the ideas of pushing the
bishop away and also kind of loosening
the b7 pawns grip and that could become
a big big juicy target for white so
Bishop e4 and now white finds another
good square Queen f6 what cousin
actually knows in these end games is
that you need not only one but how many
weaknesses in your opponent's camp so
you can win a game yes to two at least
two now cousin has a majority on the
Queen side and that's all great and well
but he needs to create some more
weaknesses on the Kings side or
somewhere in blacks position to actually
achieve a winning situation Queen f6 h5
and actually as it turns out h5 is the
move that throws the game away and we
will soon see why h4 he fixes this pawn
fixes this weakness so it can go further
and can't have any threats like h4 h3
Bishop f5 rogue d5 and this roughly 5
move is actually a very good one because
it has a double threat it threatens to
take on e5 and also hints at the idea of
c5 c6 Bishop e6 would be an idea but
then we would take on e5 and there's no
harm done to the D fabric because we
would just take okay and
Queen c1 queen takes e5 Bishop e6 rugby
for Luke a8 now this is a typical
situation in winning physicians you
already won the pond but you have some
certain issues
what are certain issues that might is
facing in this position in this heavy
rockin game yeah yeah we need some
coordination in the position but how
could we coordinate our pieces as white
g3 would just open up more threats and
actually he could go Bishop h3 setting
up nasty nasty ideas which were badly
trying to avoid which one of our pieces
a little bit loose and weak yes the
bishop on f1 so we need to defend that
so we goes Queenie to teenage King h7 in
fact Carson was setting up a very nice
little trick here if Frug goes to a 1
then cousin would obviously jump at the
opportunity give a check King goes away
and clean be 5 and suddenly we don't
care about the bishop anymore because
that looming mating threat is just much
more important and there's a good reason
that Gosselin avoided this because even
if he takes the foot bishop the check
King h2 another check here
ruk a three and after f3 we will ask
what he wants and he should just resign
as he can do anything here therefore
Galvan does something else in place King
age seven instead of Roque one after
rook d1 wide achieved his first goal
getting rid of this annoying Queen Queen
c3
Queenie four notice that first cousin
did everything to repel all the threats
that Galvan could have and then he
starts repositioning his pieces and
preferably in the center like the Queen
on e4 the screen on e4 which
coincidentally hits hits on this old is
going on here hits on b7 and let's see
if this works
hits on b7 and kind of eyes the King as
well so Queen e4 is a very good
centralizing move that you should always
make if you have Queens on the board
root K one kind of a desperado rook
takes a one queen takes a one now why
was rook takes Eve a one such a good
move in this position yes yes so indeed
we're trying and we're striving for less
pieces when we were pawn up so that's
what cousin goes for Queen takes a one
and starts pushing his pawn queen c3
green takes b7 just following just what
you said let's exchange all the pieces
I just want to Queen my pawn Queen e1
and again Carson comes up with the theme
that actually happened before and plays
a very strong move here yes c6 would
caught the Queen off a little bit so you
didn't play c6 but you're close no
so c6 wasn't played because that would
kind of cut the Queen out of the action
and Carson doesn't want that yes
b6 yes
Bishop c4 Queen f3 well he still needs a
defender around the Kings side so he
doesn't get made it but after that these
brutal pawns that that are actually
virtually like tanks are in full motion
are going to promote by themselves also
the problem is twofold for black because
the King cannot defend the f7 pawn and
this Bishop will have multiple duties it
cannot also cannot just defend against
the threat of b7 because I'll start
taking all their pawns on the King side
so Galvan plays Queen B 1 B 7 Queen B 5
C 6 there should be 5 but after Queen g3
those tanks got mobilized and caused and
got his first win but what's really
astounding that this was just his first
win against Galvan he's going to do this
again against Kalin with white with
black he's going to do it with black so
when you're preparing against Gelfand
you can notice that he's always striving
for the main main variations so cousin
chose a very very clever route of trying
to undermine this advantage of Gelfand
d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight f3 d5 Knight
c3 97 and we might think that he is
trying to play some sort of Ragusan with
this move order in fact what he's trying
to achieve here is a variation where
gelfand Boris Gelfand is forced to play
Bishop g5 but there was a big chance
that Galvin would aim for the e3 Mehran
variation with Queen c2 and this is not
the type of game he was aiming for he
wanted an unbalanced position he could
go for a win
ninety-seven Bishop g5 and now c6 III
Queen a5 and now we entered a very
topical line which is called the
Cambridge Springs opening this actually
featured in the Karpov Kasparov match
and had and given a good result for
Kasparov he actually beat carpet with
black in this line why I'm showing the
opening is because cause and strategy is
hard to understand without the beginning
phase the opening phase because this is
the way he gets the needed advantage
which we which he will nurse till the
end so C takes d5 Knight takes d5 rook
c1 Knight c3 BC Bishop a3 notice that
he's trying to win as many tempos as
possible so he can catch up the
development for white Brooksie to b6
Bishop d3 now this Bishop on d3 is
fairly annoying so he gets rid of that
the bishop a6 castle castle I mean he
takes takes castle II for rook e8
creating a little bit of space in f8 for
the bishop so it can hop back to f8
later on e5 h6
C 592 C 2 XE takes and rook c8 and as
the computer points out again is and I
put this pawn structure up here with a
purpose black is playing for this
endgame so if we know that this is the
pawn structure that we will have in the
endgame
what will be cousins upcoming strategy
in this heavy piece and game any ideas
yes
trade pieces cuz in the long term he's
going to use he's going to use these
pawns to his advantage and the more
pieces got exchanged the more chance
he will have to win so he's actually
just in the preview just like in the
previous game he's going for a long-term
advantage instead of an immediate
advantage tonight see for so seemingly
caused him blunder the piece but he
finds a very nice saving move yes Queen
where Queen a6 then that could take on a
three with the Queen yes Queen a4 then I
can take with my knight on a three if
you take on rook if you take on c4
immediately you just lose an exchange so
cousin finds the only move which is
Queen B five
there is no Knight takes now because I
can just take your queen so he has to
take with the Queen rook takes c4 and
first mission accomplished we exchanged
some pieces off we're almost there
between b5 at four so he didn't exchange
yet but after rooks in seven he did go
for Queen takes a three rook c4 Brooke
c4 takes now the d4 pawn is hanging so
it has to get defended bishop f23 c7 now
if you have a strategy you have to be
consistent
so this Queen goes on and goes back home
just to defend those two fellows so it
can be useful later on rook c1 Queen B
seven Queen d6 and if we know our plans
you know what move to play here yep
rook c8 would be also an option actually
play not have faith first and now played
rook c8 takes takes d5 he takes d5 Queen
takes d5
and we get this Queen endgame which is
already a huge achievement for black
it's my no means winning for black to be
honest it's still a game it's relatively
equal but calls and gradually out plays
Gaffin indisposition now there's a
theory in chess and endgame theory what
you should do when your opponent has a
black squared bishop where should you
post your pawns yes light squares from
that knowledge we can guess cousins next
move b5 would drop the pawn on a7 so we
have to be careful with the Queen side
pawns right now yes Queen a6 well it
doesn't help us with the pawn structure
because we're trying to create a good
pawn structure for black in this
position yes yes g6 first and what were
you saying
yes
g6 which should deserve one exclamation
mark no wonder it's an game exclam it
should actually get more than that I'll
tell you why because the bishop on f2 is
dark-squared and our King side is kind
of in potential danger if the position
opens up there and even though g6 is
very sound and logical move because
we're putting the pawn and later on the
pawns on the white squares but we're on
the danger of getting mated maybe it's
not sure that it will happen but it can
potentially be a problem if the bishop
for one way or another could land on f6
it might land on f6 after some potential
g4 and Bishop h4 f6 ideas so something
like this Bishop f4 first the g4 idea
and Bishop page 4 and Bishop f6 but
Carlsen is a clear pragmatic player and
he believes that he has enough counter
play even before that would happen and
the computer seems to agree with him
King G - how could we continue here yes
h5 that's what he will play next King g7
a3 h5 and after setting up a blockade
and actually what makes this whole plan
possible is this blockading a six-night
this night actually just as an umbrella
takes away the all-important d4 d5
squares which would help whites to enter
blacks position but because this night
is so strong on e6 that's unlikely to
happen h4 and some commentators praised
this move I still don't like it the
reason I dislike this move it gives away
the square on h4 from the bishop which
would be just fantastic
stick if it could land there for some
reason or with some move orders h4
between c2 now the plan is fairly simple
for black don't get mated and promote
your pawns queen b7 queen a for now
cousin knows the main points of Queen
and games you have to get an active
Queen and gap fun does the same
he's also next in game expert and he
activates the Queen on b7 now we have
this nasty little threat of snatching
that pawn and then rolling with our own
pawns
so Queen f3 happens I said I suppose
Gelson noticed that Queenie 7 is just
going nowhere and after say some move
like King g8 there's no real threat
there's no Queen e8 because we just take
it and the Queen on f6 would do
absolutely nothing and actually would
just dampen the scope of this screen you
can just take on a3 for example or just
Queenie for if we believe that our
centralized screen will be powerful
enough so Queen a4 with the threat of
taking on a4 Queen f3 b5 black so Lee
starts strolling and pushing his pawns
on the Queen side f5 f5 is a good move
why is that fine such a great move in
this position yeah
yeah just a terrible acts kingside
position and also hope for a better
Bishop because this Bishop on f2 was
merely a spectator defending this
healthy g3 pawn but apart from that it
does nothing else at five G takes f five
Queen takes F five in now cousins move
as cold-blooded but but it's very good
how did calls them continue in this
position Queen g4 would give White's
upon advantage because white would take
in the e7 pawn drops
in order to find this move we have to
realize what black is playing for what
is black playing for in this position
not necessarily trading the Queen's off
that's not the ultimate goal of this
position no black is actually going for
the whole point he's not trying to give
a perpetual he might if he's forced to
but already b5 was a sign that he has
some intentions intentions soon yes
a5 or to take on a 3-2 Queen so in order
to create some chances he takes a risk
and takes this pawn so his pawn can
start moving freely until promotion
obviously it won't be an easy ride but
if he doesn't take the pawn on a3
there's no way he can win this game but
cousland figures that he has enough
chances to give a perpetual if
everything goes awry and if things will
go well for him he might actually win
the game green takes h5 a 5 again these
brotherly tanks marching towards the
finish line and just hopes la jumping
through the Queen if that's possible
don't think so
so a5 they're just trying to march in so
gelfand is in a rush now he needs to
come up with a good plan so it gives a
Czech King f8 and what's the first move
that would come up for us with white
what's the first natural move that we
would make here yeah yes yeah
age five and shockingly that's a mistake
and now the reason why this is a mistake
is because the Queen on g4 is not active
enough later analysis showed that
Queenie four would have been much better
and let's say before check and chasing
the Queen around and then trying to set
up some traps would have been much
better trying to go for perpetual Zoar
getting the Queen more active would
having a better chance to achieve a draw
but h5 is not good because the Queen is
too passive right now so cousin seizes
the chance and does what galvan missed
in this position he activates his queen
and puts it on c1 now what makes this
move such a super-duper move is that it
stops this idea of h6
because we'll just take and also and it
also threatens
pc6 check and if the King could wander
to d7 at some important moments the King
would be very safe and it turns out that
black already has a huge advantage
Queenie for b4 there's no danger by now
for black because this Queen just
controls this important square on h6
Bishop e3 obviously gal font rise to the
challenge left between c7 and again the
hero of this game is this not only 6 it
seemingly does nothing but it covers the
same all-important g7 square for example
if check King g8 is even possible and
after here King gate 7 and there's no
apparent checkmate on g7
the bishop needs to move back and white
runs out of threats and the only thing
black will need to do is just to push
the
so he plays Queen a a check King g7 and
again not afraid of ghosts h6 King h7
not afraid of anything
Queenie for King g8 and I'm sure that
Boris Gelfand was looking and staring at
this position in disbelief because we're
used to the fact that if you have so
many black holes on f6 and g7 and you
have a dark squared Bishop you should be
like winning or something but there's
nothing of sorts this night just stops
everything clean a8 King Queen d8 2898
so I assume Carolyn was in time trouble
already so he's trying to go and stop
these spawns but cousin is in his
element and goes in defensive green f3
he goes on the aggressive aggressive
sorry King Queen f3 a4 King g4 knight c6
now
usually these pawns are unstoppable once
they're on the third or second rank but
they're far from that so they need some
support with the knight knight c6 Bishop
c1 Knight a5 here comes the support with
the Knight Bishop d2 b3
now obviously Galvan can't take because
b2 and just promotes next just promotes
two Queen so he plays King d3 but here
cousin comes up with a very nice
sacrificial idea
yeah yes
Knight c4 and again the same tactical
trick white can't take because b2 when
we promote and with the support of the
night these two pawns are able to
promote again Bishop C 3 a 3 and as we
talked about it when the pawns reached
the third or the second it's very
difficult to stop those pawns so g4
engage 7 a very nice waiting move just
stopping any tricky ideas on the
kingside g5 King g6 Bishop d4 b2 and
king c2 92 and there's no way this b1
promotion could be stopped
therefore galvan resigned the moral of
the story is if you want to build a
perfect game and I think these two games
from cousin was almost nearing
perfection he went and nursed a small
little advantage that he could use in
the endgame exchanged off most of the
pieces and just converted it now I want
to continue and possibly end with a
fantastic match he played in 2007 that
he played against a potential challenger
he might face now after the candidates
can anyone guess who that player could
be and who he already faced in the
candidates in 2007 ELISA you can also
guess if you're watching this yes
Levon Aronian they faced off in 2007 in
the AL East of World Cup and actually
the winner of that match was Levon
Aronian
but they played brilliant chess so I'm
going to show both of these games that
were played there so let's start off
with this game cousin was already
trailing
our onion in this game Aronian already
was trailing in this match and cousin
had to go out all for a win so night f3c
for his usual rate II that he plays
Knight c3 Bishop e7 rookie want a very
topical idea aiming to get an e4 d4
Hedgehog position the 5c takes d5 Knight
takes d5 and cousin plays d4 now this is
a surprising decision you wouldn't want
to aim for an endgame when you're
pointing down and trying to win but
cousin has other ideas Knight c3 B takes
c3 Bishop e4 Knight e5 surprisingly
cousin aims for more exchanges takes
takes castle II for and now we can see
what cousin was aiming for he gets this
to healthy central pawns which could be
used in the endgame in the form of a
passer and in this way he will
potentially get chances to play for a
win later on in a later stage of the
game Queen c8 Queen g4 Bishop f6 Knight
f3 can gauge it h4 96
Bishop g5 takes takes takes takes on f6
takes C takes d4 d5 and this is the
position I wanted to show you how should
white continue in this position yeah
obviously your trade Queens you don't
really have any other options
Queen take C cream take c8 will take c8
d 5 now this is a big big pawn on d5 why
it will always have chances to push for
a win with a passer like that it's
actually a protected pass pawn so that's
even better
now I'm have to reiterate and mention
this theory
of the endgame how many advantages we
need to win an endgame or a position yes
at least two I need to emphasize that
because this is a crucial part of the
game and you will see both calls in and
Aronian will use this theorem in both of
their games 95 so we have one super pawn
on d5 but that's not enough for a win
so Carlsen comes up with another idea to
create another weakness in blacks
position so it's white to move and
create more threats in blacks position
okay please
g4g for Woodmoor more be like a weakness
although I understand you want to play
g5 but you're actually trying to soften
up blacks position yes yes h5 and in
fact after night c4 yes he is aiming for
night h4 but first and foremost he wants
to play eight-six creating back rank
issues for black and also softening this
square which should actually be red so
this Square will be pivotal in the
upcoming battle and some people like to
claim that this idea of h5 h6 wasn't
good enough I disagree I think h5 h6
is the move that clinched this game for
Carlsen it might not be the computers
choice but from a human's perspective
it's very difficult to to play positions
when you already have too many
weaknesses computers might find the
concrete win like winning 25 moves but
you'll never find those but if you
understand this concept of two
weaknesses you could win the game
without any knowledge of a 25 move
sequence you that you'll never find so
rooks c3 so rook c1 rook c8 rook takes
c3 rook takes c3 and now Carson comes up
with a spectacular maneuver which
doesn't mean it's not a normal move but
it has unique idea behind it yes
well if you go Knight f3 you lose a lot
of time and what you don't want to give
black in this position is time because
it's time what he's lacking the King on
age 8 is just desperately caught off of
all the forces if it would be on e7
black would be even bordering of being
better the king is very caught off on h8
so that's what caused unused and play
Knight f5 and I thinks f5 its kind of
forced because otherwise the de pawn
will start rolling and we don't want
that and we can see how powerful this 86
move was now rooks e1 is deadly if black
takes take take and I just checkmate you
immediately if the upon was on h4 this
would be nothing came with King would
just jump out to g7 and that's not a
problem for black that's how powerful
the eight-six move was so he took on f5
he takes f5 King g8 and now the King
hurries to f8 e 7 and d6 the only thing
that he missed I assume is an unique
idea by white yes
if d6 I'll just come with my king and
just go closer
if Vogue d1 then I'll just go in front
of the pawn even if you do that I'll
just come with my king in front of it if
I manage to bring my king in front of
your pawn it's very difficult to push
through the king you need more support
f4 well that's an idea but most probably
Out playing at faith and still fight on
so the move he played was rookie four
can anybody help me what what could be
the idea of rookie four in this position
yes that's the main idea of rookie for
aiming to go in and g4 and route g7 or
even rook g8 sometimes so not that one
rook GA so for example King f8 as you
mentioned this was played to rook c7
rook g7 yes yeah going for the second
weakness and now this is just too much
and erroneous position just crumbles b5
takes King g8 check again because the
rook wants out d6 rook d7 and again the
black king is trapped King f3
it's an endgame so we use the advantage
of having an extra king before king g4
takes rook F 7 o k6 g for king g 8 8 7
go back where you come from King h8 g 5
and the second pass pawn will decide as
the king will just March up to f5 and g6
and wide Ollie won the game now cousin
is not the only one with the talent of
converting very good middle game
positions 11 Aronian is one of them and
this is from the same candidates match
they played
and it's white to move and play a very
very strong move you can already see
that our own Ian's position is already
dominating but it's not decisive yet so
he still needs to do some grunt work to
get to actory
yes bond f6 bond f6 after a rookie 5 and
I'll gobble up that pawn on f6 so what
might be Lee needs here are some active
pieces because the rogue does a great
job on g3 pressuring the g6 pawn but it
needs a little bit of the support yeah
h4 h4 I take you yes and that's what our
own young played now there's a lot of
pressure on the g6 pawn and potentially
white can also threaten rook g4 ideas
and chase black away or just king g2 and
set up other nasty threats like rook f3
so black those cleaning v and as we're
talking endgame here obviously our own
young took rook takes e5 f4 rook e8 and
now comes your move f6 and what's great
about f6 that it again locks this King
in forever
and this king will feel the pain later
on because it cannot really be part of
the action Bishop d7 and now there's
only one thing left that we need to do
as we talked about the two weaknesses
theory you only need to find another way
to crash through there will be the
critical square we will crush it we will
be crashing through yeah you're right
you said if
both of you are correct 'if five is
going to be the key square an erroneous
Terfel e plays around that so as you
said 'if i've is not possible yet
because black would just take the pawn
and be happy now we don't want black
happy just yet
so Brooke III threatening this 'if I've
idea but we're not going to play it yet
b5 takes takes now e5 after clarifying
the Queen side we're ready to play e5
now because of this f6 pawn black is
kind of waiting for the game to finish
because he barely can move his King
arunya uses that to full extinct for the
full extent King f2 King g8 black is
just basically waiting he can't do
anything else
h4 now comes your idea trying to probe
you with h5 King g8 King he won but
there's no hurry for white Kia faith
king d2 so before he does anything he
improves his King so it's closer to the
C pawn while also defending this if III
rook eight-six Bishop d3 he gradually
improves all his pieces and now he has a
clear target on g6 h5 and now he felt
the time is nigh and he played a six
takes Bishop takes g6 and the rook if it
moves it would just drop the e6 pawn and
that would just promote easily here so
obviously he had to sacrifice but
Aronian just wraps it up easily as he
starts taking all the pawns and he
gradually won this endgame in the last
game I wanted to show is another
comeback from cousin in this position
very similar to the previous game that
Aronian wad he will create an anchor in
blacks position yep Bishop f6 again
setting up some deadly ideas with Queen
h6 Knight g5 which would be too much to
bear so our onion takes as he has no
other choice
takes Knight d5 just in time
so if Queen eight six that would just
drop the F six pawn therefore white
plays Bishop e4 getting rid of this very
very good defender Queen f4 comes as a
savior we should be five Queen takes h4
Knight xh4 a takes d5 rugby for and it's
very surprising to have these f6
positions with both colors with reversed
players now it's cousins turn to show
how important and how powerful this f6
pawn is now we already know having an f6
pawn won't win us the game we need to
add more fuel to the fire
Bishop c8 now how could we improve our
pieces yes
look everyone you mean look everyone is
away and also if we know the basic rules
we don't like nights on the side so he
brings that night back as soon as he can
so after defending this f6 Pont
defending the c3 pawn he goes back with
the knight and jumps and plans to jump
on e5
ok 8 h4 he doesn't play Knight e5
because he doesn't like blundering Luke
takes c3 because that's not a good way
to end a winning position so he goes h4
which actually has multiple purposes it
gets rid of these back rank problems and
also hints on the idea of h5 so aged 695
okay one takes takes King age two ok
three and now what's very good about
cousin that he doesn't really panic that
often he doesn't feel too bad about the
c3 pawn because he realized that he
could go for a juicy pawn on f7 so he
checks king gage 7f 4 he wants that pawn
is badly and quickly as possible so he
can start running with his own pot rook
takes c3 and he plays h5 g takes h5 is
kind of forced and after f5 which would
be a bit hasty but maybe still good
rook f8 he played with f8 instead row K
3 and now f5 takes rook takes f7 he
achieved his goal he has a strong efj
I've Knight a very very dangerous f6
passer and this should be a clincher and
it will clinch very soon King g8 from g7
check King f8 rugby 7 what is rugby 7
setting up yes
one thing it sets up mating idea of it
will be eight and it also allows Y to
push the pawn later on with f7 f8 which
would have been impossible that the rook
on g7 so it brings it to a better square
okay eight he defends against that King
g3 as we talked about it
he likes to bring his king when it's
possible it's also in an extra advantage
for white as the black king is kind of
caught off now with this amount of
advantage already in the position it's
not surprising that he's going to win
very soon rook the 8th King f4 because
White's pieces are just kind of swarming
around the black King which will
eventually tell now Bishop b4 Bishop e6
wouldn't work because I have Knight G 6
check and both leads to mate rookie
seven mates linking g8 from g7 also
mates so Bishop b4 g3 defending
everything before getting into any
trouble
c3 rook f7 check King g8 Rho G 7 check
and get faith 97 and there is no good
square for Aronian because King g8 would
run again into mookie 7 mate so he had
to take take and he resigned because he
saw that this pawn won't run too far
away because after rook c7 calls and
wraps up the game and he continued his
fight in the candidate even though
Aronian in the end won this hard-fought
battle in the candidates tournament so
these are the games of cousin and the
ways he's trying to nourish small
advantages in to victory in the late and
game thank you so much
[Music]